i'm very um nervous for what's on your
2021 list
do you have anything prepared please
don't write it down
it will be all right i need everyone to
listen up because i know some of you
have messaged me
i promise i will not make a 2021 list i
know a lot of you think
me and this journal are responsible for
everything
and i take responsibility i i will say
this could be on me
and i will not make a list in 2021
no goals list no goals i don't even want
to say
just like wake up tomorrow no no no
shh no goal no goal
okay excuse my looks i'm just you know
uh
you know in the middle of hitting rock
bottom but i
found my goal list that i made
in december for my goals for 2020.
okay tell me if this is not hilarious
all right
go one make more money i've you know
been unemployed since march
travel more lose weight
be more social
i wrote cry less cry less cry let's have
card every single day of this whole
fantastic
um spend more time
how
first of all what has this last few days
been like for you
okay i don't even know like like this is
insane
everything about 2020 is insane so even
though this is so amazing
it is so 20 20. like obviously this
would happen
like i've worked so hard for so many
years and not even like a little break
and then 2020 when i can't get my roots
done i have a full-blown mustache
i can't leave my apartment that is when
like everything
that is so 20 20. like i always want to
be like
what are you i can't get a make-up
person on set you know
but this is so crazy and then the
celebrities i'm a celebrity junkie
that's why like when you guys reached
out i kind of like freaked because like
this
this is my genre you know i just like
love celebrity news
and things like that so this is a
celebrity aspect
i don't know if you saw but chloe and
courtney got to a fight on my instagram
wall
they like were like fighting over me
wait
break that down okay i'm like 45 minutes
of sleep
but the so i'm going to mess up exactly
what was said first off
jennifer garner posted my video on her
walk
okay so that alone is like i mean we
should all just retire because it's not
gonna get better than that
or so i thought uh chloe then commented
on her video like something really nice
and that alone kept me up till four in
the morning then i slept for like two
hours
woke up took all these messages
you're fighting on your wall like you
don't understand like i've been watching
the kardashians since season one like
back when they worked
at dash and chris was in the bathroom on
the phone
and like they were so mean to her when
like really like she's the genius
she's the genius anyway they were
fighting they were like
because chloe was like oh my god you're
so funny and then
courtney was like i love you this is not
what they wrote i'm picking this up but
it was something
on the line and then uh
chloe was like stop following where i'm
posting
and then courtney writes
stop commenting on videos i'm posting in
the group chat
i i don't even know i i don't even know
i don't even have
words that there is a kardashian jenna
group chat
that i'm in like not technically like
they haven't invited me
but my video isn't then like they spent
a significant amount of time talking
about you in their group chef
like i don't i think you don't even know
like you you don't even know
like i know like you don't even know
this is so insane
so now i have to well first off you
gotta get chris jenner on the phone
because i know she gives the stamp of
approval
for the christmas party invite and like
i am ready to take 800 cova tests i am
ready
like you can do whatever you want my
only
like rule is i don't want it to be at
kim's house
because she's white furniture and i'm
not
like i spill a lot you know um doesn't
chris have like all
black everything in her house you need
to do it at her house i need a place
where like
if i spill something and i go oh my god
i'm so sorry i'll pay for the couch
that they're not like oh it's six
million dollars you know
so that's what we need we need like oh
my god is this happening
this has been such an awful year and
everyone's just like telling me what
they're going through
and that they too like lost people or
they too lost their job or they to have
been depressed
and it has just been so my only goal in
life has been to make people laugh
and the fact that in the crappiest year
that i'm able to like make people's day
just
this much better is all i've ever wanted
so the whole thing is just
amazing like laughing and crying at the
same time has been my entire 20 20.
so that is 20 20. i mean i'm kind of
doing it now
like i'm happy but i'm still crying
because i'm i'm broken
so who else do we had we had jennifer
garner i think we had chelsea handler
okay chelsea handler wrote this is very
funny and just a little back story
i went to school for acting and then i
didn't know i didn't know i want to be a
comedian i loved comics but i didn't
that's not what i wanted to do and then
in my early 20s
chelsea handler like had her first book
come out and she was so big
and i loved her so she was performing at
the regatta
in atlantic city so me and my best
friend drove we live in new york
uh drove to the regatta and saw her and
like oh my gosh she was
hilarious and i was like oh my god she's
so bad and then fast forward 10 years
i got to perform at the bregada and like
i had my parents sit in the exact seats
that i was sitting at when i saw chelsea
handler
so like when she wrote like this is very
funny i don't even think she knows like
what a full circle i've had just
starting with her
it i mean out of all it was just
okay so um you've had a lot of people
commenting has anybody
dm'd you or anything like um
okay let me think all right i think the
best
was kyle richards i really
love the housewives i cannot explain i
go back and forth like which is the best
whether it's new york new jersey
or beverly hills lately on beverly hills
and kyle is like
you know so anyway when i saw that you
posted it did i i sent her a little
i split in her dm let's be clear i don't
want to get the story twisted
i slid into her dms and i was like hi i
didn't say that i was like oh my god
but i was like hi ah thank you again i
didn't write that i was like oh my god
and then she was like oh my god my
husband wrote like i sent the video to
like a hundred people my husband and i
like can't stop laughing
and then i'm so delirious i was like oh
my god i'm so embarrassed
right back i was like oh tell hubby i
say hi
i'm not friends with that i don't know
her i don't know these people
and like i like being like oh no i'm
sent on set
to watch you read it and so i haven't
spoken her since so i'm pretty sure that
printer may have handed you like what
the hell
so you know that was but that was
amazing i don't think she understood
like the level that was
and then um i really have to thank um
the instagram account tanks good news
because
i had sent it to him and he posted it
and
although it started going viral like the
day before
once he posted it it was just then the
chain reaction
um so i feel like and it's funny his
whole account is about like good news
and good stories
and i honestly feel like i'm one of his
good news because he doesn't even know
the chain reaction he
started people keep saying they see my
video and it was oh this is such a cool
story okay
someone posted the video but didn't tag
me okay which
happens a lot whatever what do you do
then ellen
pompeo of grey's anatomy
retweets it and again i'm not eating the
tan so i don't know
and she writes something like by the way
biggest grace fan like i've been
watching since season one
i've watched it through multiple times i
watched it at night to go to sleep i
know that's a weird
show to watch go to sleep but there's
something very comforting about them
okay so anyway
she retweets it with like a caption oh
we should get her on the show
go to one of the producers like we
should get her on the show she has that
rock bottom lab breakdown thing going
on which then the producer writes back
like yes or perfect or whatever
and then like just a random person was
like shouldn't someone tag at robin
shawl
because there was a whole conversation
of like big things going on and like no
one
no one tells me so that i count on my my
followers they've been keeping me up
because they're like just as invested as
i am in this
well this is one of those things where
you're like okay but are you guys joking
or
can i really come on grey's anatomy
i like already bought a plane ticket
like writing
what did you say i was on the show like
what's your um
what's your dream dramatic storyline on
grey's anatomy
oh my god what a good question okay all
right they
bring back mcsteamy i know
i don't want to do spoiler even though
like 20 seasons ago
something happens to him but they can't
really bring him back
but i don't just her in case you're 17
seasons behind
but i would have him bring him back
right i come in
because i just got into a car accident
i'm in a lot of pain
and then he looks at me and he's like oh
wow i'm a plastic surgeon
you're the most beautiful person i've
ever seen and then i read oh my goodness
and then we have this like crazy love
scene in
the like you know room where they sleep
yep
that's
and then the credits roll okay so you
find this list
that you actually made in 2019 about
your goals in 2020
and you start going through it and what
what's going through your mind
it was thursday night okay it was like
11 30 at night
i am just in my feels like things this
has been a really bad year this is and
just
just one hit after the next and i just
was just i
poured myself a big glass of wine i was
drinking it and then
i'm like trying to be optimistic that
stand-up comedy will come back
so i'm going through all my old
notebooks so i could try to start
writing again
and in the notebook where is it okay and
then in one of my notebooks this is one
of them from last year
let me there's someone's phone number
written here i don't know whoever number
that is i don't know
mcsteamy's right find the goal um
like the actual goal list that i had to
have written in december
um and i'm reading it and i'm
laughing so like by myself like laughing
and just
crying um at how ridiculous and how
everything i've wanted and hoped for out
of my life for a year
every single thing was just like no
just no and not just no for you know for
the entire planet
no and i was just laughing and crying
that i
i made the video i didn't even think you
know i usually put so much time and
effort into videos
and this one i just was just like a raw
moment
it was not like it was a moment where
you didn't think you know um
and uh i made it and i posted it just
thinking oh my god people are gonna find
this funny
not everyone i had at 4 000 followers or
maybe not even maybe 3 000 followers at
the time
and i usually got like you know 300
views
uh so i was like oh this will make
people laugh and then i went to sleep
and it just it struck a chord with
people it really did
so i'm so sorry to hear about i hear
about your grandmother by the way but
what do you think she would think of her
um super stardom
um well first off um just to
respect to my family both my
grandmothers died three weeks apart
so it was it was a double whammy the
grandma here which is my grandma sue
that's what i do all the filming with
but then three weeks later to the day my
other grandma passed away
and this was back during the panda in
the pika pandemic when you couldn't have
any
we had to be less than five people and
you couldn't even hug
your parents so it was the darkest
of days um so i just wanna because i i
know i have both sides of my family that
are gonna tune in to watch this
so it was just said this specific this
is grandma sue now grandmaster liked to
make videos with me
she was an entertainer not like an
actual one but like in our
heart and like soul we would make videos
all the time
we would live stream and when we would
live stream she honestly
thought like people that would come in
were her fans like she would go
hi my fans you know and then she'd go
send me money and i'm like no
you can't ask that you go what they're
my fans like you know
so she loves we're making videos she
really did she she
ate it up and um i like i'm not a super
like
you know not spirit i have a spiritual
person but like i don't like
making like oh this angel did it for me
this is a case where i think my angel
pulled some strings and i know she's
looking down and she's not saying like
oh robin i'm so happy for you she's like
oh my god my fans
like jennifer garner it was upset that i
passed
you know like send me money
kris jenner send me money you've been
unemployed since
march now you have this like kind of
viral moment that you gotta like
kind of take hold of so if you had to
put something out there manifest
what would you what do you what do you
want to do okay
here are the things i want to manifest
the kardashian christmas party
i know we're looking at jobs but look we
have to be honest
life is rough what do we need we need to
get invited to that
that jenner kardashian christmas party
two
we need dunkin donuts to realize i'm a
big fan of donuts
and say hey robin would you like to be
in a commercial but i keep my goals low
then three um i really love performing
and making people laugh
it's not just like a a moment right now
this has been my passion my entire life
is making people laugh
so if this can just if i could just keep
doing what i'm doing these last three
days
i'm good we're invested in you now where
do we go watch you
okay so if you want to watch me you can
follow me on
instagram at robinshowcomic i'm posting
this entire journey in the instagram
stories
uh and it is thrilling it is
thrilling uh so you can follow my
instagram also i go live on youtube at
11 a.m
for a coffee talk with robin shaw uh and
my youtube is
just robin really everything's just
robin's y'all and then
okay i have a goal oh no oh god
okay i have a goal i think this is gonna
be really funny so like i'm
guessing like they like what are they
doing with times square for new year's
like can we not do it because of like
gatherings
yeah i doubt it i mean i think it would
be so
funny if they don't do anything and then
i'm standing in front of the ball
and i'm like hello new york and then the
camera pans and there's no people
you know except for like my mom in the
corner with like with one little like
twirly
you know and then i'll be like all right
let's count down and then there's no
one there i feel like they'd be the like
such symbolism of like
what 2020 was so that's like a goal
but now that i set it a goal i'm
assuming i'll be home in this apartment
you